in news.
That will surprise absolutely no one.
But yet it's still being misreported somehow.
We now have eight Trump staffers who attended
the Trump rally in Tulsa on Saturday or who
were there that day.
Some of them were actually sent home early
because they got the virus who have tested
positive for Corona virus.
Remember that on Saturday we learned that
six Trump staffers tested positive for Corona
virus.
Trump was furious that the news got out that
they had tested positive.
We now got a new statement from the Trump
campaign which says that, quote, After another
round of testing for campaign staff in Tulsa,
two additional members of the advance team
tested positive for the Corona virus.
These staff members attended the rally but
were wearing masks during the entire event.
Upon the positive tests, the campaign immediately
activated established quarantine and contact
tracing protocols.
So in the midst of all of this, two Secret
Service agents also tested positive for Corona
virus.
So we have to clarify the misinformation.
We've been dealing with this virus now for,
what, four months that we know of.
In reality, even that we knew about even longer
in reality.
And you're immediately seeing every nonsense
reaction that you can imagine from Trump and
from some other people on the right to this
news.
So, first of all, this line about the last
two staffers got the virus, even though they
wore masks during the entire event.
This is causing some people to say, see, look,
masks don't even do anything.
Masks do work.
We have a new study that says the faster countries
obtained wide spread numbers of masks, the
faster they suppress the spread of Corona
virus.
Also, remember that the rally didn't require
masks.
So whether masks do or don't work, which they
do, the rally goers weren't wearing masks.
But the most important element of confusion
is that nobody is saying any of these staffers
caught the virus at the rally.
In fact, six of the eight staffers who were
who tested positive were part of the adventure.
They were all part of the advance team, but
six of them left before the rally even started.
In other words, clearly, they got the virus
sometime last week, incubated it for, you
know, 48 hours, a few days, and then tested
positive on Saturday and were sent home.
These other two staffers, we have no reason
to believe that they actually caught this
at the rally, not to mention they could have
caught it in Tulsa, but not at the rally where
they were wearing masks and instead somewhere
else.
We have something called an incubation period.
So right away, this is bad news, right?
That this is more proof the rally shouldn't
have happened because the rally didn't require
people to wear masks.
And you have these low information, Trump
ists, who say this is proof you don't even
need masks because they don't work.
No, that's that's not the right story.
That's not the right story at all.
Now, what we should be seeing is the take
away from news that eight Trump staffers,
plus two Secret Service agents caught the
virus around the time of the rally.
Is that the rally was a really bad idea with
sixty 60, 200 people there, plus countless
staff and law enforcement and others.
What are the odds that these eight people
were the only people in the place with the
virus that day?
Let's grant that these eight didn't catch
it at the rally because I don't think they
did.
There are obviously other people who were
there that day who also were incubating the
virus and they had caught it elsewhere and
nobody was required to wear masks.
Now, that being said, no method is 100 percent
foolproof, right?
Masks are useful.
If everybody's wearing them, that dramatically
reduces the chance of spread.
But it's just a numbers game.
If you put 60, 200 people indoors, even if
they all wear masks, someone is likely to
catch the virus through one of those less
likely contagion methods we've learned over
the last few months.
Surface contagion is not that common, right?
Early on, there was a lot about sanitizing
and bleaching your vegetables and food.
And boxes, the first you take out all of the
stuff.
Turns out that the surface contagion is actually
quite, quite rare.
But if you have 60, 200 people together, you
can have a one in 6000 incident.
And that still means someone catches the virus
through a surface contact.
Someone takes their mask off for a second
and sneezes on a door handle.
Someone 15 seconds later opens the door and
then has to adjust their mask and touches
their eyes.
And there you've got it right.
Even a very unlikely event when you have 60,
200 people together becomes far more likely.
This is where the rules come from.
Her guidelines come from about.
It's better if you're not in groups of more
than 10.
Why?
Because with fewer than 10 people, a one in
a thousand contagion method is very unlikely
to happen with 60 200 people.
A one in a thousand contagious contagion method
or risk is likely to now have six instances
of contagion.
I think that most of you sort of understand
the math.
When will we know the effect of the rally
on cases in Oklahoma?
We may never know.
We have to understand that because unless
we get contact tracing news, because cases
are exploding in general in Oklahoma, we may
never really know the effect of that one rally.
As you can see in Oklahoma, we're putting
a case chart up on the screen.
The cases were already spiking from the day
before the rally.
And they've continued to spike.
It takes about 10 to 14 days to know the full
effect of contagion from any particular event.
So we may never really know because cases
are spiking in Oklahoma in general now.
Some good news from here in Massachusetts.
We had the protests against police brutality
two weeks ago.
Almost everybody was wearing masks.
And Massachusetts numbers continue to improve.
So what we are learning again is the masks
do work, which we knew already.
And that is reassuring, to say the least.